دعوات حكوميه بريطانيه لمعالجه ارتفاع
معدلات الهجره الى بريطانيا عن طريقه فرض
اجراءات اكثر حزما على الطلاب والعمال
الاجانب الذين ياتون مع عائلاتهم
وبالارقام فقد بلغ عدد التاشيرات التي
منحت لافراد عائلات الطلاب 22 بالمئه فيما
تضاعف عدد تاشيرات العمال الاجانب
وعائلاتهم ثلاث مرات تقريبا منذ العام
وهناك حوالي 700 الف شخص دخلوا الى
بريطانيا العام الماضي اكثر ممن غادروها
الجامعات من جياتها تعترض على هذه القيود
لاعتمادها على اموال الطلاب الاجانب في ظل
عدم حصول هذه الجامعات على اموال من
الحكومه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات